bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de chroniques de profs tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier toutes les
personnes qui m'ont félicité et
encouragé congratuler répudier pas
répudier bref vous avez été très
nombreux à porter des commentaires
positifs et constructifs à ma première
vidéo ce qui explique mon retour ici
aujourd'hui
alors sans plus attendre c'est parti
pour un nouvel épisode
pour cet épisode j'ai décidé de taper
d'un grand coup de poing sur la table et
de mettre un terme aux idées reçues sur
le moyen-âge mais d'abord c'est quoi le
moyen-âge les hommes du xiiie siècle ne
se définissait pas en disant moi je
viens du moyen âge comme on pourrait
dire moi je viens de le terme a été
inventé juste à la période suivante à la
renaissance qui commence à environ au
xvème siècle
donc là on a l'idée générale tout de
suite nous sommes la renaissance nos
brillants par notre âme et notre pensée
par contre avant c'était très moyen
c'était plus comme l' empire romain qui
était évoluer s'était pas encore comme
nous on va appeler ça moyen-âge ils vont
pas se plaindre et sont déjà morts le
moyen-âge est aussi une période qui dure
environ mille ans il est donc beaucoup
plus long que toutes les périodes qui
ont suivi et de ce fait on peut pas
résumer simplement au seigneur et au
château fort il est beaucoup plus
complexe et il ya eu énormément
d'évolution et d'innovation sur cette
période
généralement on considère qu'ils
commencent en 476 c'est à dire à la
chute de l'empiré romain d'occident doit
aussi le faire débuter au baptême de
clovis qui a lieu entre 496 et 507 on
n'a pas de source assez précises pour le
savoir contrairement à votre prof de
primaire qui nous affirmait que c'était
en 496 pour la date de fin on a
plusieurs possibilités la fin de la
guerre de cent ans en 1453 ou encore la
chute de constantinople qui a lieu la
même année la découverte de l'amérique
par christophe colomb en 1492 ou encore
la réforme protestante de 1517 tous les
changements qui amène à une nouvelle
période se font lentement les dates de
début et de fin sont au final assez
vague
on parle aussi de haut moyen âge pour le
début de cette période et de bas
moyen-âge pour ces derniers siècles
on peut donc dire que le moyen-âge
connaît des hauts et des bas comme
premières idées reçues on peut parler du
droit de cuissage dont vous avez
probablement déjà entendu parler et dont
vous savez peut-être même ce qu'il en
est réellement le droit de cuissage et
cette idée reçue qu'au moyen-âge
lorsqu'un vassal ou un cerf se marier le
seigneur avait le droit de profiter de
la jeune mariée le soir de ses noces
avant le marié lui-même elles vivent les
barrières allez je vais raconter mon
impôt bien entendu il est très peu
probable que ce droit et étaient
pratiqués surtout on ne retrouve dans
aucun texte de loi
si quelques seniors peu sympathiques ont
pu profiter de leur statut pour faire ce
genre de choses ce n'était pas approuvée
par la loi le droit de cuissage est une
aventure postérieure au moyen-âge il
apparaît au 16e
siècle et elle est surtout repris par
les lumières puis après la révolution
française pour dénigrer le système
féodal de l'ancien régime alors les
enfants paient les idées que vous avez
proposé pour plombé la popularité d'un
seigneur ils nous prenaient tout notre
argent par les impôts c'est pas possible
ça dansante en plus personne n'y croit
rope la suite il fabriquait des
protéines à partir de nos morts et nous
les faisait manger sans qu'on le sache
danton on a dit plus d'alcool pour toi
ils baisent no spam
j'aime bien ça c'est simple ça parle aux
gens mc à dire qu'ils les laissent le
soir de leur meneur s'ajoute un petit
aspect romantique au tragique a doté ce
droit est donc repris et commentés est
considéré comme ayant existé par
certains historiens du 19e siècle tels
que je me cheikh est pourtant loin
d'être une bulle on a aussi jean
florimont boudon de saint-amand écrivain
archéologues qui en 1818 site un texte
du moyen-âge soi-disant authentique mais
dont on n'a jamais retrouvé de trace ici
et la carte statut du droit de primauté
de d'effleurements que le seigneur de la
terre et seigneuries de blanquefort a et
doit avoir un bla bla bla toutes et
chacune des filles nobles qui se marie
en ladite seigneurie le premier jour des
noces donc ce texte existe uniquement
dans un livre du 19e siècle le droit de
cuissage est aujourd'hui démentie mais
on retrouve encore dans la culture
populaire par exemple dans le film
braveheart soul et employés sous le
terme de primes adoptif alors d'accord
mais si on est là c'est pas cool ce qui
arrive et votre femme et ce qui est
encore moins cool c'est faire un film
sur un personnage qui a existé qui a
mené une rébellion dont l'importance est
immense et de données pour raisons à
cette rébellion a droit qui n'a jamais
existé
merde
vous êtes qui vous bonjour je viens du
moyen-âge nous reprenons cette émission
en ayant la chance de recevoir une
invitée venue du moyen-âge ce que je ne
m'explique pas mais elle pourra sûrement
nous apporter des tas de précisions sur
cette période par exemple un compte ou
telle journée
je me suis levé je me suis lavé tutela v
j'en suis fort aise car dans le top 15
des bonnes raisons même pas vivre
moyen-âge d'hôpitaux on raconte que vous
ne connaissez pas l'hygiène c'est
n'importe quoi
j'adore aller au bar francs plus c'est
relaxant en effet on imagine à tort
l'homme médiéval comme quelqu'un de
salles qui auraient peur de l'eau mais
en réalité se baigner est une pratique
courante menées sur des le xiième siècle
grâce aux sources par exemple à paris au
xiiie siècle compteront 27 étude des
sortes de bains publics puisque tout le
monde n'avait pas les moyens de se
baigner chez soi dans les campagnes on
se baigne dans les lacs ou dans les
rivières utilise aussi des plantes et
autres produits naturels pour se laver
les cheveux se blanchir les devants etc
quand on n'a pas le temps de prendre un
bain avec une toilette partiel une fois
habillé du visage et des mains
on utilise des savons qu'ils sont
souvent un mélange de graisses descendre
et d'huile l'on marche des herbes pour
avoir bonne haleine bref les gens au
moyen âge sont propres et c'était la
renaissance que les choses vont changer
déjà au xvème siècle les d'un public
commence à poser problème car on les
accuse d'être des lieux de débauche que
l'église de faire fermer
en plus de cela on commençait les
accusés de transmettre rapidement
certaines maladies
que la peste du coup les bains publics
ferment d'autant qu'une autre idée
commence à se répandre
on pense que la dilatation des pores
provoquée par les bains affaibli le
corps alors qu'une bonne couche de
crasse nous protège de toutes les
maladies
jusqu'à la fin du xviie siècle les
nobles fuir comme la peste et sont
rapidement imité par le reste de la
population
à la place et j'utilise des parfums des
cosmétiques pour donner l'impression de
ne pas trop plu et à part ça c'est la
renaissance exactement taille d'une
feuille là si on parlait des famines
maintenant c'est bien connu au moyen-âge
tout le monde meurt de faim c'est pas
vrai ce matin j'ai mangé du pain et même
qu'après j'avais plus faire du saut j'en
suis ravi
et il est vrai que les périodes de
famine sont beaucoup plus rare qu'on
pourrait le croire au moyen-âge d'abord
entre les cinquième et le septième
siècle rend compte que trois ans suite à
l'époque carolingienne on en compte
quatre
entre 845 et l'an mil de l'an mil à 1350
les choses se gâtent et on compte en
tout onze années de famine
la population augmente et plus on est de
fous au moyen de riz aux 14e 15e siècle
en compte quand même pas mal de famine à
cause du climat qui est plutôt frisquet
et de la guerre de cent ans qui
n'arrange pas les choses
tu me donnes les dates que je sache
qu'en faire des réserves bien sûr il ya
aussi de nombreuses périodes de disette
mais on constate que les vrais famine
sont plutôt rares ensuite on a aussi
tendance à associer le moyen-âge au
malade il est omniprésente
alors oui il ya de nombreuses maladies
au moyen-âge n'est pas tout à la fois la
variole disparaît dans la partie nord de
la france au 9e siècle la peste
bubonique fait des ravages
jusqu'au huitième siècle seulement ce
qui est donc loin de concerner toute la
période du moyen-âge jamais entendu
parler de ce malade
la lèpre diminue fortement mais ray
apparaît à partir du 12ème siècle à
cause de nouvelles relations avec le
proche orient qui lui est assez touchés
d'ailleurs tu sais comment on dit
bonjour à l'épreuve on lui serre la main
et on lui rend non en l'isie par sa part
hier elle a sûrement fait la sorcellerie
qu'on méritait sa part contre la peste
noire le grand ennemi apparaît à partir
de 1347 en europe avec une première
épidémie qui arrivent par la
méditerranée et là c'est une main
bien efficace elle allège la france 2 41
% de sa population ce qui n'est pas
négligeable
elle réapparaît trois fois au 14e siècle
et 12 fois pour xvème siècle c'est la
maladie la plus terrible qui connut
moyen âge mais n'apparaît sur ces deux
derniers siècles sont période de milan
en gros je suis né à la pierre péan
possible super et on va terminer dans la
joie et la bonne humeur sur un thème que
tout le monde aime la mort si c'est
encore déprimant je rentre chez moi tu
peux pas on dit souvent que moyenâgeux
l'espérance de vie était de 30 ans voire
moins c'est vrai mais on oublie souvent
que les enfants sont également comptés
dans ce calcul il est vrai que la
mortalité infantile est très élevé
jusqu'au xviiie siècle ce qui fait donc
chuter les statistiques et la vente de
libre tu peux atteindre les 60 ans avec
un peu de chance tout à fait possible
encore plus si tu es
voilà j'espère que ce nouvel épisode
vous a tout autant plus est instruit que
le précédent encore une fois n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne à
partager cette vidéo et à me dire ce que
vous en avez pensé parce que j'ai adoré
avoir des retours sont en premier
épisode d'ailleurs s'il ya des sujets
que vous voulez que je traite du
problème est suggéré j'ai déjà pas mal
d'idées en stock mais si le sujet vous
proposez me plaît je pourrais peut-être
en faire une vidéo
moi je vous parle d'en proposer merci
d'avoir regardé gala prochaine